the pot shep facility in western russia
set up to destroy the country's cold war
stockpile of chemical weapons the gas is
burned or neutralized chemically
russia has the know-how to help syria do
the same and that is acceptable to the
syrian regime
the assad government is most likely to
accept an international team
there will be us experts
but the scandinavian countries with
their reputations for neutrality will
also be
what killed these people and how large
is the stockpile of chemical weapons in
syria
the u.s says damascus has about 1 000
tons of chemical agents for sarin and
mustard gas manufactured at four sites
and stored at 40 dumps
but tracking them down in a war zone is
risky
you'll need a protective force
i can't imagine that us or nato soldiers
will be given access to syrian arms
dumps
so they'll have to cooperate with the
syrians or turn to the russians
russia is a major ally of the assad
regime
but how much influence does moscow have
in damascus really
under the russian plan syria's chemical
weapons are to be destroyed but how is
that going to take place
they could take the weapons out of the
country by ship and destroy them in
russia
using the new plants which were built
with german help
and the process can take years even in
peace time
despite the modern planted pot ship
russia is behind schedule and will miss
its 2012 deadline for eradicating its
own chemical weapons